The eternal problem is: how do you deal with tragedy and evil?
And you can say, "I'm not ready." Yeah fine.
Not surprising, especially if you were too protected as a child.
it is not a good idea to protect children too much
because snakes are coming into the garden anyway
so instead of driving away snakes
You have to arm your child with something that will help them cut the snakes into pieces.
And make them a world.
The trick to flourish people in the face of suffering and evil is strength, not protection.
It's completely different. We also know it from practice.
For example, we know that when you treat agoraphobia by exhibiting,
which is, roughly speaking, a fear of chaos, fear of everything.
You don't want them to be less afraid, but to be more brave "
It's not the same because agoraphobics have this problem:
They cannot imagine death and suffering.
They are naive, that there is no imagination in the theater,
because they are protected before.
But then something happens, this often happens to women in their forties,
because agoraphobia most often develops.
Something happens, the authorities have protected them from chaos for life.
So maybe they had too protective a father
and they went to a too protective friend and then a husband
and maybe they were willing to blame everyone for the protection.
This is an agreement - they will remain weak and dependent, but they may,
because only then will they attract a person who is hyper-protective.
but the price is that they are not strong enough.
And then something happens in their lives, often in their forties,
they develop heart palpitations, possibly as a result of menopause.
Their heart starts to beat furiously, and they think they will die.
Well, with whom do you talk about it, right?
The authority will not protect you from this.
Or maybe their friends divorce or the sister dies or something.
It provokes a specter of mortality and perhaps a specter of evil and mortality.
And so that escape to authority cannot solve it.
So they get a panic attack.
They go out, scare, feel their heart beating,
then they are terrified because of their heart, because they think, "Now I'm going to die".
And they will say:
"I will die and make myself a fool because I will draw a lot of attention."
So two big fears will be: death and public embarrassment.
Then they get a panic attack, primitive instincts get out of control.
Very uncomfortable.
Then they start to avoid places where they have a panic attack
and finally they can't go anywhere.
Tiamat returned. Big monster, little victim.
And what do you do with them?
You can't say Tiamat doesn't exist.
It is not possible. They're no longer naive.
They had direct contact with the threat of death and social court.
They met a terrible mother and a terrible father and there is no way back.
You can't say "The world is safe".
It's not safe at all. Not safe.
If you think it's safe, you live in a naive bubble,
that culture gave you. It's a gift.
And now shattered and what do you do now?
You hide at home and you can't go anywhere.
You're a petrified rabbit.
And life is hell because you can't work.
The alternative is to: take apart the things you are afraid of.
We'll expose you to them. Careful and orderly.
And then you learn that you're tougher than you thought.
You didn't know it! And maybe you didn't want to take that responsibility,
because people are the creators of their misfortune.
When you had the opportunity to go out and explore
or to withdraw the fear, you have chosen to withdraw with fear.
It's not just that you were too protected,
Often you were willing to take advantage of being protected
and you escaped whenever you could.
Maybe you were a kid on the playground and you had a problem with other kids.
And deep in your mind you know that you should deal with it yourself.
But you go and tell your mom and let her hit.
And you know it's not right.
You know you're breaking a social rule, but it's easier.
So you run to authority and hide behind a big father, right?
The problem is that you don't learn it yourself.
And then you have to learn it painfully when you're 40.
So you go out with people.
You say, "What are you afraid of? Number it 1-10."
Make a list of the 10 things you're afraid of.
10 is what you fear the least. Let's start with it. "I'm afraid of elevators"
Okay, let's take a look at the elevator picture.
Imagine you are in the elevator.
Go out and see how the horrible jaws of death open,
because that's how you react symbolically to it.
And you go as close as you can.
You go and it works. You're very nervous
especially because of expectations.
You are shivering, going out, stopping, looking and calming down.
You do it ten times and you're fine.
You've learned that you don't die, but more importantly,
You have learned that you can withstand the threat of death.
And then you go a little closer, and then a little closer
And finally you are back in what is not an elevator, symbolically it is a tomb
It's a closed and isolated place.
And you will learn: "Hmm, it turns out I will stand."
And then you're more together, much more confident.
And what often happens in such situations,
I've seen it several times,
When someone goes through this exposure process and gets rough,
they often start building other people like never before,
because he could not stand up for himself,
because he didn't want to undermine the protection.
If you protect me, I can't resist you,
because I can't afford to lose your protection.
So if I play this, I'll hide for you,
then I can't challenge you.
That's not good because ...
you often see it in men,
he is still afraid of the father's opinion when he is 30-40.
Why?
Because they want to believe someone out there knows.
so they are willing to accept the subordination,
because it does not force them to question the idea that there is someone out there who knows.
Because that's the advantage of a father as a judge, right?
He knows.
And what if not?
What if someone doesn't know better than you? Well, that's hard.
Until you realize it, you're not an adult, are you?
This is technically the point of reaching adulthood.
Nobody knows what you should do better than you do.
It's a terrible finding because what the hell do you know?
It's a terrible finding and people often choose slavery ...
Permanent slavery to the spirit of the great father before finding it, and it is understandable.
But the problem with this is that you have more than you think
and when you hide behind that person
you will never have a chance to understand that there is more in you than you think
much more than you think.
Maybe there's so much in you
that you will endure the threat of death without asking you.
You may even put an end to the threat of evil without asking you to.
Who knows? It's definitely possible.
And it's not an abstract question.
It is exactly the question you are dealing with during psychotherapy.
You always address this question and the answer is often positive.
Because people can be incredibly argued.
And you know that because people work in the emergency room in hospitals
or work in palliative care or morgue.
These people have damn hard work.
Or they are at the forefront of investigating child abuse
so they regularly meet evil,
These are very stressful jobs, but people do them,
Some people even do it without damaging them.
But that's harder because you can see scary things
you will never forget.